e dopo che mi hanno censurato il video
perché dicevano che c'era il sesso in
quel video il sesso visto che sono
visibilmente nervoso e ho bisogno di
calmarmi in attimo
facciamo un videogame che distende i
nervi bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
tra i die repeat repeat in dialetto
significa riri di ridipingere cioè
poveri verniciare quindi provaci muori
rivernicia storia costosi nembro one ok
dove devo andare spiegate ma da chi
storia quindi a che figata
devo fare da ponte con me stesso morto
che è perfetto fantastico 9 beh sa cosa
geniale non ho ancora fatto videogioco
così si ok però dovete togliervi va bene
a [ __ ]
ecco adesso mi uso come si va beh ma non
è che possono iniziare dall inizio ogni
volta che due palle io credevo fosse una
roba tipo range game ma così mica mi
sganascio i maroni ma dai anche due
[ __ ]
se non fosse che nei check point non ci
si può credere in aula bensì stesse
illuminati a quella quali sono i
dirigenti della fabbrica in realtà sono
i nemici fantastico bene avrà come primo
livello non era facile sistema si
affacci ragazze del dirigente
veramente no aspetta il mio ho capito
e quando torna giù questa società aiuto
mi chieti poi chaumet rilascio ha
frenato il prof.re così teste di minchia
lo sapevo senti frate è già difficile
farlo normalmente figuriamoci così ti
giuro veramente ammazzo qualcuno se non
ho parole
ok ok mi chiamo un forzato i nomi che
regga veramente questo qua ragazze
quando avete il ciclo giuro provate a
giocar sta roba ci avesse un mese
montate la famiglia non so perché c'è
una roba proprio tragica questo gioco e
tragico vi giuro
ok non farlo o non fa scherzi eh ti devo
sfruttare la famiglia non aspettano
capito pecchia come vuoi morire hanno
capito spiegami come vuoi morire come ho
perso cosa che imho ver
tua madre proprio [ __ ] quindi devo
arrivare alla ho capito
purtroppo devo arrivare prima del tizio
ceramica questo che si sta sbloccando
ferocia uno slip in bocca non si capisce
interessi
si vabbè però mica è impossibile non ci
arrivò mai alla fine un tentativo solo
praticamente che se sbaglio una volta ho
perse va bene gavin qia veloce testa di
culo quanto ci mette perfetto vai è
possibile non avere che è impossibile
giuro quanti problemi no dai ragazzi dai
ragazzi dai ma dai tristia no non è
possibile da infami perde dai perfetto
si contento festa di culo due almeno non
mi fa rivedere il filmato che non me ne
frega una miglia e se condanna vagina
questa è l'occhio di sauron cos'è quella
roba lì non solo devo video fare pure
veloce perché se muoio devo rifarlo da
zero dovrebbe darmi pure il filmato c'è
il massimo della vita a [ __ ] a certo
veloce
no non sono morto non solo molto poco
non sono morti daimi che cos'è un
infermiere questo dai ragazzi non sono
morto però mi che almeno quando non devo
morire non mi fate morire che già
difficile cristo si va beh ma mica per
quanto poco tempo chance in quanto poco
tempo abbiamo già vi ho perso ho già
perso
non posso già più vincere cioè
impossibile
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai noli porca
eva devi morire più avanti c'è veramente
vi giuro preferivo giocare a super meat
boy mi chiamerà 20 confronto era era la
gioia supermicro è che cazzo vuoi dalla
vita mia ho provato a saltare non salta
porca eva meno quello
o
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai non li
finito finito il tempo fitto ma in tutto
il tempo porta avanti perché io ho
deciso di far ma dove l'ho trovato il
suo gioco di merda ci sono tanti giochi
butch gta cesta falla skyrim è uscito
dalla st merda giocavano parole non ho
veramente parole ma cosa aveva sul
bianco era solo il pd è vabbè cosa devo
fare io della mia vita cosa devo fare
spiega mi cosa devo fare e cosa non ti
fa non lo so non so parliamone perché mi
chiedi ti ammazzerei di schiaffi non ho
capito frate veloce veloce degli andare
veloce vi girano i [ __ ] non lavorano
parole non devo morire neanche una volta
in poche parole anche una dove devo fare
tutto giusto tutto tutte le combinazioni
perfette vabbè ok moke repoli beh adesso
un tentativo so se muoio perso se muoio
perso perché non c'è più tempo poi
perfetto perfetto veloce veloce veloce
veloce velocissimo qualcosa a casa non è
possibile non è possibile
no dai non è vero non è vero il vero lei
roma va a fan culo dentro da ero dentro
cosa ma [ __ ] dai c'è ma poi
ragazzi questo è veramente iso non ho
mai giocato una roba così difficile
penso sia veramente il gioco più
difficile che io abbia mai fatto che è
più difficile ride words are the game
c'è chi giura e tra è veramente assurdo
è difficilissimo veramente non ho mai
giocato nella pa così ecco tua madre
[ __ ] coeva impossibile ragazze
impossibile non ho mai giocato una roba
così incredibile perché mi devi fare
richiedere il filmato dovrà fare un
cazzo me ne vado e me ne vado me ne vado
me ne vado
no sì sì sì per un ed ha finito è finito
così nuora per fare sta roba incredibile
freedom e freddo sta minkia è caduto
l'illuminato lì ma il bayern rodolfo
rodolfo di ath luca stand hub
[Musica]
la musica finale e geniale rinnova beh
veramente c'è questa roba qui ma quindi
seclì cosa hai finito proprio come un
gioco di merda bellissimo ei ragazzi è
stato bello soprattutto due non rifarei
adesso per noi facciamo di nuovo
veramente non so cosa erano parole
quando penso che mi mancava un passo per
vincere barra è una tragedia sta roba
mai più amaramente mai più una roba così
orribile è affatto un livello è
ringraziando iddio papera gazzoli spero
che vi sia piaciuto il momento non mi
piace anche a pace di facebook e come
descrizione travestiti siete ci vediamo
il prossimo video per ragazzi